zen et sabrina vous vous êtes rencontrés
à la télé vous vivez le parfait amour
vous êtes actuellement candidat dans les
vacances des anges et vous pensez qu'on
peut trouver l'amour arrêtez vous aimez
vous avez vraiment parce que je pense
que c'est vrai gilts à peut-être réseau
ce que tu dis mon pas faire d'exception
des généralités
parce que l'amour pour moi tu peux le
rencontrer n'importe où tu peux
rencontrer au travail tu peux le
rencontrer à la télé le rencontrer dans
le métro ou ailleurs je vais dire ce
serait très dommage de généraliser ça et
je pense que ça cause de ça qu'on
diabolise les histoires d'amour à la
télé et que justement elles sont cette
étiquette
voilà de fake et et je trouve ça dommage
parce que nous on en a la preuve
aujourd'hui voilà on s'est rencontré sur
une émission de télé c'est un endroit et
ben voilà peut-être qui nous rapproche
un peu plus parce qu'on partage une
expérience très forte
on vit ensemble h24 je pense que vous
déjà entre vous en travaillant ensemble
vous avez des alors nous
[Rires]
la longue race noire on ne peut pas
attraper des maladies j'entende je veux
dire que ça crée des liens
bien sûr c'est la métier mais c'est mon
amitié bien sexualité non non mais dans
une télé salle je rappelle que n'ai pas
dit si oui non mais ce qu'ils aiment à
dans une télé c'est un petit peu comme
une colonie de vacances majorité des
jeunes dont entre 18 et 25 ans ensemble
dans un cadre paradisiaque
ou bien les caméras oublier tout ça mais
on n'oublie pas mais l'appareil en
voyant des jeux vous nous regardez nous
suivre n ont jamais regardé nous
aiderait rapprochement si vous doublez
non mais des jeunes entre 50 et 70 louis
sûr qu'il se passera